we're in gabon on the west coast of
central africa at the invitation of its
government
they are flying us deep into the jungle
the aim to help us understand more about
one of the most forested nations on the
planet
from above the canopy you get a real
sense of the sheer scale of this forest
stretching for hundreds of miles in
every direction and covering nearly 90
percent of gabon it's part of the congo
basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
gabon has been able to afford to leave
this jungle alone because it's an
oil-rich nation
but prices are plummeting
production dwindling and so that's about
to change
you have to read the trees this is the
akumi tree
lee white is the country's british-born
environment minister
percent of our economy is going to
disappear in the next twenty years
as as oil revenues disappear we have to
replace
um
those revenues with something else
that's something else is the forest
gabon wants the international community
to pay it for careful conservation or
risk deforestation for logging and
agriculture
i think it would be very difficult
to maintain
forests long term
without a real partnership
between
developed and developing countries
and without
a business model an economic model that
makes rainforest valuable for the people
that that live in them
firstly we are looking for
forest elephants here we have two
species of elephants we have a savannah
and the forest elephant
degrading the forest would put one of
the most biodiverse regions on the
planet at risk
in lope national park we see just some
of the wildlife that lives here
a family of chimps crossing the savannah
and later forest elephants
more than fifty thousand of them live in
gabon sixty percent of the world's
population
but even here climate change is having
an impact warmer temperatures reducing
fruit growth on trees pushing the
elephants into villages
that is
uh the big problem in gabon
every day there are in that plantation
to eat the plants like cassava
everything which
the the woman plant
that night evidence on our doorstep of
the problem a group of 12 foraging near
our lodge
as climate change intensifies so does
the fragility and importance of this
ecosystem
gabon is one of the few countries on
earth that absorbs more carbon than it
emits it's why this whole region is
crucial to the battle against climate
change and why what happens here will
matter far beyond national borders
this is the strength of gabon's
negotiating position at the cop 26 u.n
climate summit later this year
tongi gahuma bakali is the man making
the argument for a new carbon market
that rewards conservation because of the
need to become emerging countries all
tropical countries in the world lose
their forest
it's a fact our forests still
stunned the tree are still understand so
now
help us
to
to to not become like other tropical
countries
gabon is at a crossroads
trying to make an environmental asset
profitable without destroying it a model
for the future but only if the rest of
the world agrees
hannah thomas peter sky news in gabon